how these memories of being on my
grandma's house that she would prepare
these like beautiful plates of sashimi
which is raw fish I just look at it and
be like nope we're not not doing that
nope man that she'd fry me up a plate of
spam I grew up in Singapore which is
kind of like a giant melting pot of
cultures I did grow up eating a lot of
sushi a lot of Japanese food I ate a lot
of food on I'm from Iowa so there was
one Japanese place they would deep-fry
most things and then put it in the sushi
so I haven't haven't really had sushi
this week we're gonna learn how to make
sushi from chef Hiro at Kew sushi in
downtown LA I think like for myself I'm
kind of coming into it as a Japanese
American person so I sort of have this
heightened like anxiety about not doing
it properly
butthat said Nikki and Neil are Japanese
either so I will at least do better than
shot I'm allergic to avocado so I can I
can't have any our go
thus I can't have most sushi we're
really close your book about sushi those
guys cricketer Mary mas oh hi not okay
three please total consciousness killers
may you send you something no judge
cotton opens my stock the I don't my
style Tokyo style no and simple enough
horses this Yoko regardless next a
column from Magro bluefin tuna cap
taking my star to the Cucaracha by the
kite I stack so the horses your to cut
the missile roof Internet okay that's
huge
yeah it's one raised in Spain so what
are we looking for takes yeah this takes
deep MIT how much will this make it 300
300 pieces of sushi osuzu Coco simple
simple 9 Honduras
Osaka not Oh Wanda dick Tomas simple
desk a thermo test account and a
limousine
so the snail agonic ITT America see
Thomas da Gama dedicated in tax
hey welcome thank you
oh you gonna taste my rice what do you
put in the rice uh red vinegar and salt
red bean is very buyers no need to add
sugar about 200 years ago sugar was very
expensive
it's like crazy right yeah it's like the
perfect balance of like moist yeah
before the Tokyo style what how was
sushi like my sister came from West part
of Japan Kyoto Osaka so they use
hakudoushi empresas put some rice and
fish and press Oh ed my style
Tokyo's tester she was invented in Tokyo
no formerly Edo today we're going to
learn Tokyo style Georgia so extra
common style
this is Rick Academy which is a ring but
it tastes like I am this pursuit or
medium party pack and this is Barry this
auto row and the party spot gets very
very very buttery very party let's get
fire yeah I prefer green pad okay all
right
oh this one big cristinaw American
ibises to cuttlebug machine toaster
loggers the Americas in sir junior
sister you imagine motorist let's go
what a scene I did enough to know
associate automotive industry the mo was
of a traditional sister you're an
Acadian I never put a traditional sister
uni that poor Agassi destiny
I know I'm regarding each Tamara okay
I'll show you to cut fish
[Music]
was so nice man for the ancestors oh
yeah okay yeah boy yeah really negative
a little thick okay this is a big knife
Oh too thin maybe yeah dark horse here
[Music]
yeah
that's a good one yeah I am okay so out
of the three of us who did the best a
little bit bad you had to base ah dang
it
there's a lot of mental energy just like
trifling yeah we have so much more room
to close
yeah medium fatty part the bluefin tuna
alright so it's more slippery yes we
really have to be more careful oh you
guys this is this is the end of it all
oh yeah yeah better yeah better this is
the most difficult most difficult it has
to be very thin because very party
I'd like to apologize in advance
I think nails winning yeah good do we
catch that you heard him say good oh how
do I do this this is so bad yeah
let's make sushi well take the rice in
just the riddle you do that with one
hand take Chris just a little bit Robby
goodbye honey rice
okay oh dear yeah Oh upside-down Oh
yeah you bigger me mm-hmm yes goodbye
yeah everything everything
you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
okay okay okay we did it yeah you did on
your date
I'm pissed okay which one whoa so um
possible wash your hand oh yeah right
how did we do yeah good good would you
hire us okay sure try Sean's first
should we though Hey yes why just assign
huh all right
hmm Cheers yes there really is buttery
no I didn't like Sochi a lot because it
tasted so officially mediatic but this
is like what would you rate me out of
ten okay not bad oh I'll take that I'll
take fire your first day hey [ __ ] these
are mine you don't see that coming
Cheers very good friend I like this one
better not whiter I like that breaks
down more easily yeah okay so how did I
do
six oh I've got I was getting the German
eat down okay neo these are mine yes
these are nice scale very nice very good
wait Wow now that one's my favorite
there's the smoothest huh
no no I like that it has a bit of a bite
though you know to learn actually about
sushi is really refreshing
there's no avocado know-how picado like
I suspected one of these lines that
we've been fed not only alive 6yn wait
so I went you mean yes
thank you so much thank you thank you so
much we fun crazy everything we will do
you guys want coming here that's the
medium shower
[Music]